today on December 4th Stuart Scott ma
Day being celebrated by ESPN and all of
us in the sports world and certainly
those who spent many years with Stuart
at ESPN V org slash Stuart Scott is the
website that you should go to to donate
to the Stuart Scott Memorial Cancer
Research Fund got a direct message from
his daughter saying hey can you help
raise awareness and I thought there is
no better way than to do that then to
talk about it as much as I can with a
longtime great friend and a man who knew
Stuart longer than I did and his name is
Dan Patrick back here on the Rich Eisen
show from the show right before is the
Dan Patrick show every day between 9:00
a.m. and noon Eastern Time how are you
DP hi rich Don well so do you remember
the first time you met Stu it might have
been at a pickup football game it I
think it was something it wasn't on the
air I think that it might have been we
were playing a football game with people
from ESPN and I know that he showed up
and I think he had his ankles tastes and
and I realized he was really serious
about everything that he did and it kind
of set the stage for who he was and how
he was going to perform when he was on
the air ankles taped off that yeah he
was ready just in case
an NFL game broke out Stuart was ready
to play in the same with basketball we
showed up with head to toe Air Jordan
stuff and he picked me up full court in
a in a pickup playoff pickup game he
picked me up full court and I realized
that that's just who he was he was very
he's just competitive as anybody I ever
met so DV force you to get up is that
what you're saying he forced you to
tradition oh no it it was you know we
went toe to toe it got to the point and
John bucho graz Jason Jackson some of
these guys because I said look I don't
want to play because somebody will get
really competitive and
I'll get competitive and then it won't
end well and they said no we just run up
and down the floor we're just gonna
sweat and he picked me up full court he
did everything but slap the floor and I
went but this isn't gonna end well
it got to the point where I'd be so mad
at him because he was guarding me as if
you know the national championship was
on the line and I finally was dribbling
the ball down the floor and I said where
do you want me to score on you you bleep
any bleep and you know so it was we
competed with each other when we
anchored together yeah there was a there
was a competition but that's just who he
was I mean that's what made Stewart
great he he was so competitive he wanted
to be great he never ever ever male in
his show never
and and when he asked for he wanted
information and these are things I
always admired about him is he wanted to
tell you something different than any
other anchor he wanted to do it in a
different way than any other anchor he
was just wired to compete and even when
we did SportsCenter together we were
competing against each other well
there's no doubt about that Dan and I
know we've discussed this either off air
or on air whatever they all mesh
together now anyway but I don't know you
wanted to remove yourself from the
process of ESPN finding the person to
put next to you after ko keith olbermann
left and how there was there was a major
competition going on amongst all of us
to try and get that chair next to you
and and Stu knew I wanted it and he was
offended by how sometimes how much I
wanted it because he would tell me why
do you want to you know be the guy after
ko with Dan on a so-called big show he
goes we've got that going on right now
we're better than them he would tell me
that all the time yeah you know yeah and
and I move myself from that decision of
who I wanted to have next to me because
I said it's different who I want to work
with as opposed to who do you management
want to see on the show because it's
different because I can say hey I want
this person because I like them but they
may look at it differently and say we
want you know chemistry or you know
younger whatever it might be because
following in Oberman footsteps is you
know that was pretty daunting and I
remember that people were upset with me
because I didn't pick them and I kept
telling some of the anchors I said I'm
not making the decision and they never
believed me and I said trust me I am NOT
making this decision and then you know
they announced that they were going to
have Kenny main in there and Kenny was
different than Keith and you know it
Stuart didn't want the job because he
was competitive with either one o'clock
being already better than the 11 o'clock
that that's that's how that's how deep
it went that he didn't want to join and
follow Keith he he wanted to prove that
the one o'clock was better than the 11
o'clock so there was so much stuff that
went on be it's tough enough to do the
show live TV and then you throw in all
the other things it was like this is
crazy but it but it was a it was a great
time because there was so much talent
there and and you had to be on your game
it's because there there were people
barbarians at the gate they wanted your
job man mm-hmm and I just remember when
I started doing the NBA Finals then all
of a sudden I had people saying hey I
want to do that or they go to management
say why can't we rotate you know anchors
out there covering the NBA Finals I'm
like wow you know this this is a
competitive competitive field Dan
Patrick here on the Rich Eisen show but
when it all came down and we we did love
each other and and I think the the the
competitive spirit that we're just
talking about what Stuart is what made
it so shocking that that cancer took him
from us because I honestly thought he
was going to beat it I you know I
honestly thought that cancer will have
met its match in in Stuart and and I'm
wondering what your seat was during his
fight in his battle and and how you
viewed it DP I was on the outside of the
SPN but I never asked for anything from
ESPN after I left the only thing I'd
asked for with one person that I was
speaking to is an update on Stuart
that's it I didn't I didn't ask for
anything didn't care about anything with
ESPN I moved on but I just I I wanted to
know how he was doing because I lost my
dad to cancer and I lost him at 54 and I
you know I kept thinking about his
daughters and you know the impact that
my father dying left on my two sisters
so I you know I was obviously involved
in it but not on a first-hand basis I
reached out to Stuart prior to the SV
appearance and we wanted to have him on
the show and we were told he may not
have enough energy to get to loss in was
to do the ESPYs and you know I remember
watching that and it's one of those that
you can put you know things to decide
you know maybe we weren't as friendly as
we could have been should have been we
were very competitive I think we
respected each other but when he got up
on that stage like they're just certain
moments where you go that that that was
a man a man sized performance there like
that I don't have that in me I don't
have what he had in him that ability to
get up there and say what he said in the
way he said it and you know you're just
talking about and he knew he was dying
but you you know while you're alive that
you know use every breath you got and
when he got done with that I just sighs
crying like whoa whoa what just happened
they brought his daughter onstage I'm
not my guy I can't do this and you know
we wanted to have him on to talk about
it and you know he I think that he was
done I think he had given his message he
was done
and you know there was no victory lap
and believe me Stuart would have taken a
victory lap but I think he had done it
on that date in that day and you know I
never got a chance to say goodbye
I was in New York and my relationship
with ESPN still wasn't very good and
John skipper who was running a scan at
the time said I think you should be
there and I said I'd love to go there I
just don't want to add you know any
issues to it I would love to be in there
sit in the back and go to his wake and
John skipper arrange for a helicopter to
pick me up in New York after a show that
I was doing fly me up to Bristol get a
car take me to the wake I get there and
Darius Rucker is singing Stewart's
daughter is singing and I'm just in the
very back and I didn't want anybody to
notice me I just wanted to go okay my
respects because you know what he
certainly deserved that and then sums
that everybody if they could go back
should go back to just say thank you
because he opened up a whole different
world to SportsCenter you know Keith and
I were the older guard and Christopher
min the older guard but Stuart opened
this up and his impact on younger
sportscasters minorities cannot be
measured and I I hope that he's never
lost and you know in this you know these
memories and these anniversaries with
him that that should be remembered it
wasn't just a great speech what he did
is he helped teams
he changed the espheni help change
sportscaster I agree with you Dan DP
here Dan Patrick on the rich on this
show a few more minutes remembering our
our good friend Stuart Scott and then
just his love of life if we can spend a
couple minutes on that I mean just his
love of life and love of love and
wanting people to be together and happy
and you know I can personally speak to
that as you know to who I'm married to
and who I met there at ESPN and
and you all were at my wedding and you
were behind the bar during the
photographed portion of everything and
you were you were mixing drinks for
everybody was Stuart involved in that
process - Dan what's going on there
he might oh because he might have been
competitive and say I remember but I
always I always tell people the one
story that I'll always remember
working with him was a Sunday night hmm
and we're they're playing the the
beginning of SportsCenter the theme
music Stuart would always be putting
drops in his eyes because of his
eyesight right bad eyesight then he put
in drops and got up and left the set so
we're in the beginning we're done
senator and and he gets up at least now
I know in the next 14 seconds we're
going to be on camera he goes off his
scripts are right there in front of me
and I come out on camera did you read it
and I now have to do the first 15
minutes of SportsCenter and that means I
have to do his highlights in his words
and his on cameras can I get a witness
from the congregation a ray and Lucretia
and then so I read his highlights and my
highlights we got to the commercial he
comes back on he then we go back on
camera yeah and people were like what
happened and we had to then once we got
done with the show go back and do the
entire look what's the a block the first
15 minutes because Stuart lost his
contact lens and I did I did his portion
of my portion in the first 15 minutes
could you imagine if there was Twitter
then I mean we would have that that
would be preserved forever I could be
able to call that up right now in the
palm of my hand oh my god he never said
anything to you
he never said anything he never said hey
this what happened huh no okay laughter
the show yeah and you know he he didn't
even say to me said to somebody else
about you know he lost a contact lens
but I you know he's one of those where
you go where he's going and then you're
like welcome to SportsCenter and and you
had Stewart's pile of papers over there
oh yeah they were Danny and he would
scroll area I mean he'd be scrawling
this is his catchphrases on all of his
shot sheets so so you said hi I'm Dan
Patrick and I'm Stuart Scott or I mean
you know I think I just said hi I'm Dan
Patrick and welcome to SportsCenter and
then it's set up on prompter you know hi
I'm Dan Padua Longsight Stuart Scott and
so I just breathe through that and then
I just went into my first read because
my producers in my ear just said you
know just go to camera one we'll just
start the Sports Center and then I got
done with my highlights and then I
realized I had to go on camera
read what Stuart wrote not knowing what
Stuart wrote because I was seeing it for
the first time live on the prompter on
TV in front of the you know couple
million people so I guess you were you
and you so you handled it you were
cooler than the other side of the pillow
in other words Dan know so it's funny
because you you that that wasn't
expected there were times though that
Stuart would and I would try and hose
the other at the end of a show that was
the beginning of the show we would we
noticed that there was one anchor on the
air I'll just say his name I don't care
Bob Stevens if you remember where Big
Show Bob because one time when Keaton
Keith did a show from Shea Stadium I
think it was on the night that Jackie
Robinson was being honored and everybody
would now have to retire number 42 Bob
did the show with you and we were all
wondering hey he just got there how come
we can't get that seat which again
pissed Stewart awful that I was
complaining about it but anyway we
noticed that Bob would have the tendency
in the last segment like how many
seconds we got 50 seconds 35 seconds you
the producer would say in your ear
there's fifty seconds you're tossing a
baseball tonight all that sort of stuff
and that's how you're gonna get off the
air
we noticed that Bob would have the
tendency to take the entire time himself
and thank you as as well as a viewer and
say goodnight and you would just sit
there nodding your head the entire time
so Stewart and I would know we would say
how many how much who's gonna end the
show how much time's left and we would
give each other a furtive glance that
we're gonna big show the other and once
the producer said all right Stewart you
take it I'd be oh come on now and he
would take the entire 50 to 60 to 70
seconds sometimes and I just have to sit
there Nanak say for Rich Eisen I'm
Stuart Scott goodnight that's the way
we're analyzed yeah yes there's nothing
worse than sitting on camera nodding
your head you're the RCA Victor dog
while somebody is on camera and they're
just talking for a good sometimes you
look at them and you're not at them and
then you nod back at the camera hanging
somebody out to dry
thank I don't even get to any Sports
Talk I knew we wouldn't but it's all
good all right thanks for doing this I
just figured you know what let's get you
know you're the only one I could think
of let's talk about Stu and his legacy
and send it out there and let's
everybody go again to V org slash Stuart
Scott and raise as much money for the
stuart scott's Memorial Cancer Research
Fund thanks for that thanks for taking
part DP you got that Stan Patrick watch
again his show before hours every day
listen to it every day before ours on
audience Fox Sports Radio etc that's
right here on the Rich Eisen show again
v org slash Stuart Scott for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app